it is the annoyingly catchy ditty that
became a global phenomenon and got stuck
on repeat in millions of heads over and
over that has spawned a slew of spin-off
parodies even finding its way into
street protests for its South Korean
producers baby shark has been a bonanza
I believe baby shark is one of the top
intellectual properties dominating all
media these days it is a great present
and blessing for us but not their
intellectual property according to the
creator of this song sounds familiar
produced in 2011 by US musician Johnny
only it predates the South Korean
version and his lawyers are now baring
their teeth they're claiming plagiarism
rejecting the defense that baby shark is
actually based on an old campfire song
that no one owns we added some
originality and creative activity to the
public domain song and we think that
they copied our originality and there
seems no stopping the baby shot
juggernaut the latest spin-off baby
shark and fellow animation pink Fong go
on a space romp it's a single long movie
and yes guess what tune they're singing
too
try to find anyone who doesn't know it
[Music]
when the case was first brought last
summer the district court ruled that
Korea's copyright commission get
involved to study the two versions side
by side and give its opinion since then
the Commission has dutifully and
probably painfully been listening over
and over to baby shock doo doo doo doo
doo doo baby shocked when the court
hears the Commission's decision it could
have big implications in the world of
copyright I think it's a very unique and
interesting case in in Korean copyright
and/or international copyright law as
well but we'll do nothing for the
estimated four billion of us on this
planet who have heard it and might never
be the same again
Rob McBride al Jazeera solve